I've never had Taco Bell we're gonna get  the Crunchwrap Supreme oh my God we're  gonna add potatoes we're gonna sub guac  for sour cream we're gonna remove that  cheese we're gonna make it Fresco Style  baby we are pulling up to the Old Bell  right now oh my God it's so warm I don't  know what drugs you're putting in the  Crunchwrap Supreme Taco Bell but lordy  lordy let me be your drug mule oh this  is good and then once you get to like  the middle you really get like all the  flavors  you can't really screw up potatoes and  beans should we rank these these the  breading was fire I'm gonna go with the  eight I am giving a solid 9.5 the 0.5  Taco Bell comes when you give us some  vegan meats I'm gonna give it an 8  fun to hold I'm gonna give it an 8  [Music]